Touch over 30 years ago Sharon and I hit
bottom and filed bankruptcy we were
scared
our marriage was hanging on by a thread
we had two little babies so I was forced
to look at what I had been told my whole
life in academia and what I had been
told by this stupid but culture we live
in that you can borrow your way into
prosperity and that borrowing money is a
way to win I was forced to stop and look
at that now when I was a kid growing up
mom and dad used to take us to sales
seminars and motivational seminars they
were in the real estate business and
there's a great motivational speaker
that I had the pleasure to meet and
become friends with several years ago
I'd admired him from a distance for many
years his name is les brown he lives
over in Los Angeles this is an African
American speaker and he is a blast to
listen to unless says the people change
their lives only when they become sick
and tired of being sick and tired people
only change their lives when they
finally stop and say that's it I've had
it I'm not living like this anymore
you've got to have an I've had it moment
American Express called my house and
Toma asked my wife why she would stay
with a man that wouldn't pay her bill
his bills and she called me crying at
the office because she was thinking the
same thing I've had it with American
Express I hate that company thirty years
later I'm still pissed at them I've had
it I'm not living like this anymore
I don't borrow money anymore don't call
me and ask me when it's okay to borrow
money it's not I've had it get it you
feel it you feel how visceral that is
that's when you change your life
not when you're a wuss and you
intellectually analyze something and
come to a conclusion it doesn't work
people change behaviors when they've had
it I'm not living like this I've had it
you come home drunk again I'm done with
you you bum I've had it you hit me again
you look at these kids cross out one
more time I am out of here
I've had it people change their lives
and transform crummy conditions when
they say I've had it have you had it yet
all right you listen to this show for
entertainment and you're academically
inspired by some of the calls they call
it I watched a few of the YouTube things
and it helped me for a minute Dave
that's so ish it's a wish we're doing
Dave ish and that sucks debt sucks
stop it haven't I've had it moment have
you had in I've had it moment if you've
had one we want to talk to you that's
what this hour is it's our I've had it
theme hour when you're ready to tell
debt to kiss your butt I've had it I'm
done with that debt sucks I'm not living
this way I don't care it well my broke
stupid friends think anymore if you have
an opinion about my life you should keep
it to yourself because I'm gonna be
living it and if you want to come in and
analyze my thoughts tough when you reach
the point you don't give a crap what
other people think you have a shot at
winning for the first time in your life
until then you're trying to please a
bunch of people on Facebook or so fake
kick ants can't even find their butt
with both hands it's unbelievable if you
Instagram yours a little shallow life
away to a you've got to have a point
where you go as for me and my house
we're not doing this and you gotta have
that it's a healthy level of righteous
anger I'm sick and tired of being sick
and tired I've had it if you're there I
want to talk to you I want to hear your
story or maybe you reach that point a
while back and it changed your life and
I want to hear what was it you were what
was it you couldn't pay a bill what was
it your sick kid you couldn't pay the
doctor well
was a thing where you finally said
enough I'm gonna get this stupid money
thing
this stupid debt thing under control
when did you say enough you got to get
mad this is not an intellectual exercise
behavior modification is not an
intellectual thing it's a visceral in
your gut you got to feel it in your
chest your voice tone has to change your
octave needs to shift stuff needs to
happen baby
spit needs to fly out of your mouth when
you're talking about this you've got a
heaven I've had it moment it's the only
way it works in that that's that's how
we've gotten people out of debt for 30
years south Sharon and I have avoided
debt we just built a 70 million dollar
building with cash who does that we do
because we said we've had it 30 years
ago we don't borrow money American
Express you can kiss my butt Bank of
America you can kiss my butt visa I
don't need you to have a good life I
certainly don't need a frickin car
payment I've had it so you don't don't
you see this do you feel it and only
then will you change and permanently
change the depth of your belief the
depth of your conviction has to go
beyond an intellectual understanding
down into the visceral parts of your
soul and your spiritual walk and then
you will be transformed be not conformed
to this world but be transformed by the
renewing of your mind that's what we're
talking about here